the
east asian islands down there there's
papua new guinea okay just north of
australia anyway there you said they're
doing this to impress oh we're going to
get into this thing talking about
so basically you know they have an
average gdp per capita of 2600 that
means if you take up all the gdp in the
country and divided by the people the
average person is worth 2 600 bucks
that's basically what the average person
in america makes a month yeah so i love
it when you call me big papa new guinea
but they ain't making that money there
okay but they dropped
specifically 5.6 million dollars on a
fleet of maseratis to impress world
leaders
during a global conference in 2018 so
this is three years ago so now
three years later oh no right
the finance administer of the country
the finance minister is like i don't
know what the we were thinking in
so many words he says now three years
later the country admits that the
shallow purchase
was a quote unquote terrible mistake and
he's trying to recoup its losses by
offloading multiple maseratis at a hefty
loss oh my god dude they are the
gabrielle union of the world
they're the key pain of financial
responsibility quote unquote from the
finance minister of papua new guinea
if we had any foresight the maseratis
would have not been purchased in the
first place dude i could have told you
that right now yes
i don't know the reasons we went down
that path
of purchasing the maseratis and now we
are caught up in this dilemma and i can
tell you it was a terrible mistake
that's the same speech you give your
wife or girlfriend when you honey i was
drunk i don't know what i was thinking i
didn't think i'd spend that or be with
the strip club the maserati now thinking
about it i think you're right hon i
think that was a bad idea cars closed
jewelry bro they'll get you every time
every time every time i'm telling you it
doesn't discriminate so so you're
talking about entire country
the finance director the finance
minister of an entire country is
basically like
i don't know what the hell happened last
night bro yeah it's like a hangover
moment i don't know what the hell
happened that's exactly it we spent five
and a half million dollars for
maseratis dude whose idea was that man
and like all these world leaders show up
and they're like yeah you want to get
the maserati like no we're good let's
get down to business no i took an uber
yeah i just over here i'm good i got my
own driver yeah i'm good so now i
brought my own master now this country
with a gdp per capita of 2600 bucks per
person oh he's basically feeling shame
shame awkward conversation
hey how's the budget looking not good
bro yeah i don't know we've got 17
maseratis we've got to offload for at a
steep loss
the
is this the finance minister i don't
know i was about to ask who is this guy
is then prime minister then
prime minister key word there he's out
yikes
okay let's see what a maserati looks
like for people a beautiful car i'm sure
but not worth lowering your country's
gdp so what can we learn from this i say
this all the time
a car is to get you from pla
point a to point b again you wanna have
a nice car that's cool the average car
payment in america for a new car 550
bucks average car payment for a used car
400 bucks but the trick oh yeah it's a
sick car
is this is this going to make more
people want to do business with your
country because your finance ministers
rocking this wasting money
look cars might look good on the outside
but when money speaks money talks
they're a dumb investment it's called
appreciation versus depreciation okay
average car will drop i think 20 the day
you take it off the lot yeah you buy a
maserati for a half a million bucks boom
by the next day it's worth 400 grand not
a good look okay but there's something
bigger here that's the math side of
things right right so there's there's
the
um the technical side of things right
the um the the fiscal side of things and
then there's the behavioral emotional
side of things here's what this this guy
did or this country did
they tried to impress other people
with cool cars
and now they're stuck holding the bill
for these cars
their country has not improved their gdp
and trying to get pro impress other
people will get you in trouble yeah
that's the best lesson to learn yeah
trying to impress others
there's never get anything we buy these
things to impress other people
to look cool for other people
that don't give two shits about you give
a could give a
there's a quote out there i'm gonna i'm
gonna remember this quote but we buy
things we do things we we acquire things
to look good for people that could care
less about us there's a specific quote
i'll get it but number three it's live
with live within your means okay
not again trying to impress other people
let me tell you something if you're a
dude and you buy one of these cars
and a chick might be like oh this is
cool he's got a cool car eventually
after the third date fourth date fifth
date she realizes
you don't got that much money
yeah exactly the hard times keep this up
yeah the gas tank is on e
you're eating at horrible restaurants
you're living with your mom but you
drive a sick car yeah you know you say
fake it till you make it there's things
you're not gonna fake
okay because at some point
you're driving a ferrari or maserati and
you're making 40 grand a year she's
gonna find out why didn't they just rent
the cars why they actually buy them boom
they could have just ubered around for a
couple days what are they just running
take an
five and a half million bucks on
maseratis
um this is part of the wild money move
of the week yes this is the wild money
that's exactly we went from gabrielle
union to now papua new guinea just
making it rain
and uh
maseratis unbelievable anyway so a
lesson for for papua new guinea out
there for our people out there
um
don't do don't try to just fake it i
mean it's just the truth's going to come
out the truth shall
set you free
brother amen brother anyway
so that's our wild money moves of the
week not good look for papa new guinea
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay bro